tenemos un círculo aquí con centro en el
punto y digamos tomemos un punto
arbitrario que se encuentre fuera del
círculo vamos a pensar no sé digamos en
este punto que le vamos a llamar el
punto a y ya que hemos tomado este punto
podemos tomar dos líneas tangentes al
círculo que contengan al punto a así que
vamos a dibujar las vamos a pintar estas
líneas que sean tangentes a nuestro
círculo ahí tenemos una línea y ahora
vamos a pintar la otra línea tangente al
círculo muy bien ahora vamos a darle
nombre a estos puntos de tangencia es
decir los puntos en donde intersectan
las líneas azules con la circunferencia
digamos este va a ser el punto de y
digamos que este de aquí va a ser él
punto c ahora lo que quiero demostrar en
este vídeo es que el segmento ave es
congruente al segmento ace es decir
tienen la misma longitud y vamos a
marcar los digamos para que sea mucho
más claro voy a voy a resaltar los con
un color azul un poco más fuerte quizás
debería tomar un poco más fuerte
y vamos a tomar esta marca y como
siempre te invito a que hagas una pausa
y trates de resolver este problema esto
trata de demostrar que estos dos
segmentos son congruentes trata de
hacerlo por tu propia cuenta
muy bien vamos ahora a trabajarlo todos
juntos y lo que haré primero es
construir dos triángulos que serán como
veremos en unos segundos van a ser
triángulos rectángulos muy bien entonces
vamos a trazar este segmento del
segmento o b y el segmento c y también
vamos a trazar el segmento a o muy bien
entonces como podemos notar aquí hemos
formado dos triángulos y yo digo que
esos triángulos son rectángulos y les
voy a decir por qué y es que en el vídeo
anterior vimos que de tener un radio que
intersecta a una línea tangente entonces
forman un ángulo recto así que este
ángulo que tenemos aquí es un ángulo
recto este otro ángulo que tenemos aquí
digamos por el mismo argumento también
es un ángulo recto verdad también
sabemos que los segmentos de hilos y el
segmento o b y el segmento o se tienen
la misma longitud y es
es porque ambos segmentos son radios
verdad entonces tienen la misma longitud
otra cosa que podemos observar es que
estos dos triángulos del triángulo o ave
y el triángulo o sea a estos dos
triángulos comparten la misma hipotenusa
verdad comparten el segmento o a eso
significa digamos que las dos hipotenusa
shawn que en realidad es la misma pues
tienen tienen la misma longitud verdad
así que podemos decir que los triángulos
o ave y el triángulo o c&a tienen dos
lados iguales verdad tienen este lado
que comparten y estos dos lados que son
iguales verdad y además ambos triángulos
son rectángulos y sabemos por la
congruencia hipotenusa cateto que ya
vimos en algún vídeo anterior que si
tenemos dos triángulos cuyas hipotenusa
son iguales es verdad que sería este
caso y además tenemos que sus cut
catetos uno de cada uno son iguales
entonces ambos triángulos son
congruentes verdad es decir el triángulo
o ave es congruente al triángulo o se a
verdad y eso lo demostramos usando el
teorema de pitágoras entonces lo que
podemos concluir de esto es que la
longitud del segmento ave el segmento
ave su longitud será igual a la longitud
del segmento a ce así que aquí estamos
justamente demostrando que estos
segmentos son congruentes verdad así que
espero que con esto estés convencido de
que cada vez que tomemos un punto fuera
del círculo y trazamos segmentos
tangentes a la circunferencia entonces
esos dos segmentos serán congruentes
entre sí